alors j'allais en coin y aura une grande
tournée européenne cet été il sera le 21
juillet à golfe juan et le 22 juillet à
nîmes voilà donc si vous l'aimez
allez le voir voilà alors jamiroquai
quand on s'interroge sur cette grâce ce
que vous avez dans la dans la
composition musicale et dans
l'interprétation vocale
en fait on trouve la réponse dans votre
biographie votre mère car hennequin
s'est lancé à 14 ans dans une carrière
de chanteuse de jazz
à 17 ans elle était sur la même scène
que les beatles que ronnie scott ou
dizzy gillespie
est-ce que c'est finalement sac c'est
cette jeunesse se baigner dans la
musique qui vous a donné cette grâce oui
absolument
j'ai effectivement ma mère une influence
très importante sur moi depuis que
j'étais tout gamin
moi j'étais dans le coup lisse et
j'étais souvent avec les musiciens là et
elle va s'occuper des musiciens et les
enfants le musicien ou mais en fait
c'est sûr ça quand elle était sûre celle
là elle avait plutôt s'occuper de moi
évidemment avait des vents des grandes
des grands alors qu'ils jouaient ya de
bonnes provinces trois en tout le sont
tous à la musique que j'ai entendu qui
va bercé mon enfance et donc ça a été
vraiment une influence numéro un pour
moi c'est une très bonne école pour vous
effectivement et à l'âge de 4 ans
pendant un show de votre mère vous
entrez sur scène en criant maman maman
maman vous en souvenez de ça adieu
m'appelle parce que à l'époque très bien
avoir traversé
li danseuse bon c'est pour ça des
faucheuses j'aime autant les choux les
chaussures à l'heure actuelle parce que
j'étais toujours encadré de vie qui
était grande avec des grandes jambes des
grandes chaussures que des branches mais
c'était son sac je suis un peu fétiche
question chaussures m'enfin bon alors à
la même époque
votre premier grand témoin musical c'est
shaft par isaac hayes ça a été vraiment
pour vous une révélation
j'ai jamais vous entre avait tellement
sur moi c'est incroyable
mais si vous avez lu toutes ces infos
non mais c'est vrai c'est super mais oui
vous avez raison
effectivement mon grand père avait une
table
et puis il y avait un petit tracteur
rouge
moi je pédalais là autour de ça on a une
touche est vraiment la première fois
voir aussi que faisait partie ma mère
faisait partie du cercle des fidèles 175
jouer un jour dans un club avant qu'il
soit vraiment très connu donc
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
s'inscrit dans la durée toutes cette
histoire avec la musique
maintenant il faut que vous le demandiez
ce que vous disiez ce que j'ai vécu
donc voilà comment s'explique le bout
musicale de jamiroquai et son
instabilité aussi et puis alors on
découvre quand on étudie un petit peu
votre biographie
pourquoi vous aimez tellement les
voitures c'est parce que votre mère
n'avait pas de véritable pied-à-terre et
vous avez passé une bonne partie de
votre enfance à à l'arrière des voitures
ce qui explique votre passion pour les
bolides sans doute vous demandiez à
votre mère d'accélérer quand vous étiez
sur la route avec l acheteur est bon
c'est vrai que j'adore toujours les
sièges arrière des blessures des yeux
mais vous voyez en fait j'ai déconné
c'est vrai que j'ai grandi sur les
écoutes
c'est là que c'est là que me vient cet
amour qu'on les bosquets parce que quand
vous déplacer aux quatre coins du pays à
longueur de temps et bien tout ce qu'il
vous reste à faire passer regarder les
bagnoles et donc in zion années 70
c'était très différent que vous
intéressantes qu'elles ne sont à l'heure
actuelle elle avait une triumph bottemer
elle avait une triumph tr6 60
alors voilà c'est pas facile quand on
est enfant de bouger et de faire des
études jamiroquai jay kay a eu une
enfance un peu compliqué il n'en pense
pas facile à l'époque votre mère
travaille beaucoup parfois vous rentrez
chez vous y'a personne quand vous
rentrez et vous n'êtes pas assez grand
pour mettre la clé dans la serrure et
vous êtes obligés d'aller voir les
voisins en pleurant pour qui vous ouvre
la porte de chez vous ce n'était pas
drôle tous les jours j'ai pu être en
internat dès l'âge de 4 ans j'étais
jeune gamin de l'école j'ai été dans cet
internat différents tout simplement
parce que ma mère de mes travailler et
donc les gens ont frappé dès le premier
jour tout simplement parce que j'avais
parlé à mon camarade pendant le repas du
soir en fait j'avais pas nous aviez
droit de parler à certaines personnes
mais bon papa lui en l'occurrence et
donc c'était très strictes et donc ils
vont ils m'ont battu et je pense que ça
m'a donné l'indépendance dont je jouais
à l'heure
il faut bien voir ainsi que ça a
développé en moi cette indépendance vous
savez qu'il faut grandir rapidement
qu'il faut faire ses preuves
voilà alors en parlant d'indépendance à
l'âge de 16 ans vous discutez avec votre
mère vous devenez tagueurs vous allez
vivre dans un squat ou fait des petits
boulots et vous avez même vendu du shit
c'est vrai vous avez vendu du haschich
jay kay à afc les oiseaux qui conduit du
chiffre mais vous je pourrais d'ailleurs
bien fut même toujours maintenant ce
serait sympa mais bon il ya des fois où
il ya des moments où si vous voulez
faire de la musique et bien à ce moment
là vous allez faire tous les examens il
faut pour y arriver est effectivement là
je me suis rendu compte qu'il fallait
que je fasse un certain nombre d'efforts
avec le fasse un certain nombre de
choses que je récupère l'argent
nécessaire pour compte pour m'acheter le
matériel dont j'ai besoin pour me lancer
et puis ensuite j'ai pu sortir de tout
ça et oui moi je savais ce que je
voulais faire ça c'était j'avais quelque
chose d'eux et le fixe est là dessus sur
la musique c'était ce que je voulais
c'était vraiment et du hasch libanais
dessus en fait ça fait plein de petits
boulots pour essayer d'accumuler de
l'argent vous n'êtes pas très heureux à
cette époque là et un jour vous vous
dites si tu veux faire de la musique
fait de la musique ne fait plus que de
la musique
même si tu dois mourir de faim à ce
moment là vous retournez chez votre mère
vous vous enfermez pendant six semaines
dans la salle de bains transformé en
studio et là vous créez en très peu de
temps en fait le concept jamiroquai et
le logo le logo avec les buffalos
manière que vous inventez ça très
rapidement finalement j'ai voulu sortir
de tous les problèmes
je traversais rentrer chez moi j'étais
dans ma chambre je me suis assis là je
me dis bon alors à temps qu'est ce que
je vais faire maintenant il faut que je
fasse quelque chose que je présente
quelque chose à l'entreprise jeudi ce
que le produit fini est donc ce que je
ne trouvais pas de nom pour le groupe
donc la première chose que j'ai faite
c'est que j'ai essayé de se dessiner ce
type là bon signe parce que je me suis
dit c'est qu'un symbole que les gens les
reconnaît facilement et je me suis dit
pas si le voit régulièrement ils vont le
reconnaître même si après deux noms et
c'est le cas voilà alors le premier
producteur qui a reçu votre cassette au
départ il a cru que c'était une diva
noir en écoutant votre voix il pouvait
pas imaginer une seconde que c'était un
jeune anglais c'est une voie que vous
avez hérité de votre mère oui absolument
en fait j'ai fait une interview à radio
à londres et le type m'a dit c'est qui
cette femme noire qu'on entend la régie
banon voilà et là c'est le succès un
succès considérable et rapide vous
donnez une star mondiale vous devenez
milliardaire et vous devenez aussi
cocaïnomane vingtaine d'années ne groupe
a fortement grandi à l'époque c'était
les années rock'n'roll et les filles 8
cagnotte de la vodka lé temps rouler
donc réparé ça il ya utilisant comment
donc je pense que l'idée c'était pas
trop d'aller plus loin c'était cette
époque pour arriver à monter sur scène
c'était simplement les têtes
2les à l'ampleur de la scène et c'est
vrai quand on aime on atterrissait parce
qu'une fois que vous avez créé votre
spectacle il fallait atterrir et
l'atterrissage parfois été un peu
difficile et nous comptons bel adam
facilement ferment c'est fini maintenant
je suis toujours là j'ai été je suis
prof depuis cinq mois
oui c'est terminé et se terminer
aujourd'hui grâce à un ami à vous qui
s'appelle olic est un ami de longue date
et un jour vous rencontrez ce au lit
vous dit qu'il a des problèmes d'argent
vous lui dites que vous avez des
problèmes de drogue et vous le dit je
vais te payer pour tu me surveille et
effectivement depuis le 1er janvier 2004
vous n'avez pas pris de drogue vous avez
retrait bien là il ya quelqu'un qui a
essayé de me vendre je lui dis non a
admis ce jeudi à holly à l'époque
sénateur sur place et je l'avais
beaucoup aidé il avait voyagé pendant sa
vie pendant les tours en amérique à
l'amérique du sud un peu partout et donc
il était dans le creux de la vague et
donc je dis j'ai dit allez je les ai d
art de vivre heureux donc je dis allez
on est potes
j'ai besoin que tu m'aides à ton tour et
donc combien tu gagnes
allez je ne suis par de ton salaire tu
vas bosser pendant 24 heures sur 24 on
va se lever le matin va aller courir on
va faire ceci au travers on va arracher
toutes les pages des endroits où on peut
sortir et c'est donc et si j'avais pas
arrêté de faire ça j'aurais pas pu faire
dynamique et voilà
même chose
cet extrait du nouvel album généraux
toile
je savais
monsieur guy
alors tu accueilles de depuis que vous
avez arrêté la cocaïne nous est beaucoup
plus agréable avec les journalistes
il faut bien voir avec les paparazzi
anglais notamment c'est qu'ils sont
vraiment hyper féroce et c'est vraiment
une musique endiablée et l'autre veulent
me voir sortir des clubs un peu comme un
geste qui veulent voir site la photo qui
veulent point et donc de temps en temps
l'enfouir qui peine à trancher
tout le monde est content